[Music]
so it's a really great pleasure to be
here and when I started out I got hooked
on data back in 95 way back when it was
really just being a weird kind of geek
and all of a sudden it turns into a very
sexy job description so I have been very
lucky in my career and I am even more so
appreciate today the group of people I
have the honor to present here all of
which have merits on them own careers
having a broad background across
different areas and I hope you will
enjoy the different perspectives that we
bring to the table here to the topic on
Big Data and science so with that I
would like to introduce our first
panelist that's Gary Marcus and he is a
professor although we're taking a bit of
a break right now right on Levi
professor on leaf in neuroscience from
NYU and I would like to also point out
that he's a very accomplished writer has
contributed to New York Times and also
authored a number of books something I
never ventured to do I have great all
four people who have the discipline to
finish a book so and I think your most
recent is the future of the brain that's
right is that force coming on already oh
it's already out it's a collection of
books of essays about the brain by Nobel
Prize winner is another eminent
neuroscientist so if you're looking for
some more reading and our next speaker
that will join us is Cathy O'Neill so
Cathy and I we met when she was teaching
a course on doing data science at
Columbia who actually wrote a book about
it and she wrote another book that I
think she will spend more time talking
about yes I come in and on the lack of
availability so Cassie has a background
and method in math and her recent
publication is weapons of mass
destruction
it's a
gonna be coming out in September so and
right now you are involved also at
Columbia nope I'm oh yeah you're out
entirely I'm a data science consultant
and you can talk to me afterwards so the
next person I would like to welcome is
Duncan Watts he is a researcher at
Microsoft Research and his background is
actually in mechanics right Pete for you
theoretical applied mechanics yes
theoretical and applied mechanics oh did
I promise you a very variety of wide
variety here but I think most of your
work really was touching on areas on
social science and how people interact
networks so again a number of very
impressive and interesting books most
recently everything is obvious once you
know it or something so I you know the
answer knows you know the answer
and so he's now leading or co-founding a
team here at Microsoft Research but also
what does it mean to be a professor at
large Oh sort of honorary professor I
thought there was maybe some other kind
of quirks with names I sort of you sort
of go and visit I think once a year and
so please welcome with Duncan thank you
the final member of our panel today is
Chris Wiggins who again endorsed many
many different hats Chris Wiggins is
associated with Columbia and comes from
really biosigns and also wears a head as
chief data scientist of the New York
Times bringing experience from data
using it from medicine now also to
publishing so I really believe we have a
great kind of group together here and I
would warmly welcome you to take
advantage of the diversity we are
planning to go through kind of the types
of topics and questions that interests
us for the first half maybe and then I
would very much like to if you
participate and join us with your
question
the things that you really want to get
some answers to so for the evening I
will I think we wanted to really follow
the proposed title of what are the
what's the power and the potential and
then at some point also look at some of
the things you want to be aware of on
the perils there is also an interesting
I think differential between doing data
science in industry in applications and
how does it affect scientific endeavors
and how do we now use it to make
scientific progress and so we hopefully
will touch on on that as well so now I
get to sit down and I think um so I
wanted to really kind of have asked my
panel to reflect I think we all
benefited in some which way in our
careers from the fact that big data
became big data I'm sure we would have
made careers otherwise too but clearly
there's something that changed in the
world of data and I'm not particular
about calling it big or small or
whatever but certainly there was a
transition and what we now see today in
in the uses of data so I wanted to ask
you to reflect off some of the
highlights that you have perceived of
advances how data could be made useful
how you maybe use it today maybe some of
the scientific sites as well so with
that I will open it in no particular
order um actually I think you have many
different hats so Chris why don't you
share some of them yeah so I think in my
case and this may be true for Duncan as
well we were working in fields that
became data science long before we
started calling it data science so I was
a I started a PhD in 1993 working in
theoretical physics applied to biology
which in 1993 biologists were not really
that interested in theoretical methods
coming from theoretical physicists and
then after like in the middle of my PhD
sequencing happening happened so in the
middle my PhD in 1985 the cover of
science magazine in summer of 1995
was muffler influenza the first organism
to have its whole genome sequenced and
the whole relationship between
biological modeling and data just
completely changed and I think many
people realized it at the time I was in
it was in Burger King with some other
graduate students and one of the
graduate students
somebody another graduate student came
in it was holding science magazine and
you were like this is gonna change
everything and he was right because once
you sequence one critter once you
sequence Tomales then you know you can
sequence yeast and destroy Phila and C
elegans and basically worm and chicken
and mice and everything else and then
you can sequence humans and once you
sequence one human then you can sequence
a bunch of humans and then you know that
you can correlate your genotype with
your phenotype or you could sequence you
say multiple places within one tumor and
somebody and you can understand disease
progression in a much more detailed way
so I mean in short I was in a field that
became a data science at that time and
it was a very painful time like people
were writing essays like we don't need
the scientific method anymore because I
shouldn't have to have a hypothesis
before I get an ro1 grant from NIH I
should just collect all the data and
then ask questions later and I guess
well Duncan also was working in social
networks I really had the pleasure of
hearing Duncan talk about his work I
think in 1998 or so early days so yeah I
think for many of us like data science
happened to us long before we started
calling it data science and we had the
opportunity to think about how we would
use statistical methods and machine
learning methods to answer questions
coming from the sciences so at the times
I would say that the way we use data
science is a little different but but in
academia a lot of what we were doing was
11 things I've been doing ever since
were trying to take questions coming
from the Natural Sciences reframe those
questions as machine learning tasks and
then try to interpret the results of
those machine learning tasks to somebody
coming from a Natural Science domain so
I also started graduate school in 1993
and I was started off
working in in in applied mathematics but
in what was then called chaos theory and
then over the course of my PhD got
interested in what would now be called
network science but it was sort of
before it was called network science and
and back then and actually the problem
that I was working on was this problem
that was called a small world problem
and would be familiar to you as six
degrees of separation you know how is it
that everyone in the world is connected
or even is it true that everyone the
world is connected to everyone else
through six degrees and no the obvious
way to solve this problem is to build a
map of the entire network of the world
the friendship network of the world and
all the many billions of people and and
all of their friends and and then just
simply count two random cares the people
and say you know how many steps does it
take to get from point A to point B and
then take the average over everyone and
you know back in 1995 when I started
working on this problem that was
inconceivable I know because I tried to
conceive of it that will never happen
right and so you know my adviser Steve
Strogatz and I kind of invented this
other way around the problem a sort of
mathematicians way around the problem
and I then embarked on this career in
network science and ended up teaching
sociology at Columbia which is how I met
Chris and in rant about you know 2006
you know this is sort of now you know a
couple of years after Facebook and one
year before Twitter and it really sort
of dawned on me that what had happened
to biology in the mid-1990s was
happening to sociology that we were
becoming a computational field whether
we liked it or not and we would be
well-served to work with computer
scientists and so that at that point I
went and and went to Yahoo research and
then to Microsoft Research and I've been
working with computer scientists ever
since but but you know the the first
interesting I think I would say is that
you know several years later the
Facebook data science team actually did
the thing that was inconceivable
to me back in the in the late 1990s that
they took a billion people on Facebook
and all of their friends and they just
counted by brute force how many steps it
takes to get from anyone to anyone else
and in fact it's always less than six so
so the numbers a pretty good number but
it really the larger point I think is
that is that you we have new ways of
looking at old problems now just because
you have this data just because you have
new types of instruments that allow you
to measure things that you couldn't
measure before you can develop entirely
new approaches that would have been
quite impossible in you know in a
previous era and I think sort of in
general you know advances in science or
revolutions in science are often
preceded by innovations in
instrumentation that you build a new
kind of instrument you invent the
telescope it allows you to sort of see
into deep space for the first time and
it completely changes astronomy and then
it changes cosmology and physics and so
many other things you you invent a
microscope and allows you to see
bacteria swarming around inside a cell
and it change its biology and you know
there are all kinds of flaws in this
analogy but there's some element of
truth to it that we are you know the
internet and digital data is in some
sense akin to the telescope that we are
we have built an instrument that allows
us to make previously invisible things
visible and that should be useful for
lots of things and we'll talk more about
all the ways in which it is an imperfect
analogy and there are all kinds of
problems but there's clearly something
there and it's already having a huge
effect on the social sciences and will
continue to do so um yeah so I I started
grad school in 1994 in in theoretical
mathematics actually was a number
theorist which is like the farthest from
data science you can possibly get
although I did copy
a tional you know computational algebra
I should say I didn't do anything with
data until I left my assistant
professorship at Barnard College to
become a quant in finance and you know
finance was big data before big data the
original you know quants on finance they
were the ones that figured out how to
use data statistical like pattern
discovery to make a killing in options
or in stocks or bonds or what-have-you
so I I got that job just before the
world ended I got the job in June 2007
and within a month there was a major
earthquake in in the world of finance
and we noticed the rest of the world
probably didn't really notice until
about a year later when Lehman fell the
hedge fund I was working before was like
20% owned by Lehman so it was a big deal
when we fell and so Mike I spent two
years there and then two years at a risk
firm in finance also dealing with lots
of data especially around credit default
swaps it I think it didn't so two things
I figured out about the power of data
data like the person who has the
controls the data knows way more than
people who don't have the data that's
the first thing I learned the next thing
I learned is that that could be a bad
thing that can be a really destructive
thing and people can use their power
badly so it kind of pushed me in the
direction of becoming an activist
whereas I had been absolutely the
biggest math nerd in the world until
until then and so I kind of left finance
I became an occupier eventually and I
think I think the next step for my
activism which I'll just mention briefly
because we talked about when you have
instruments you can use them was
actually something called well it's
something called data kind now it's a
it's an organization that tries to help
NGOs use their data well at the time it
was called data without borders and we
had a hackathon and my job and we talked
about how hackathons don't usually get
much accomplished because you only have
24 hours to try to open up a data set
well my data set was the stop-and-frisk
data set and the people I was working
with I was like managing a team of data
scientists to work with this data set
that the NYC Lu had brought they said
look we want to understand what's going
on in the stop-and-frisk data which by
the way like a lawsuit had forced that
the NYPD to like publicly show but like
this thing about it is the New York
Police Department they did put they did
sort of post this data but you know
format that no one could open in
particularly no one who at the NYC Lu
they were not a technical reticent
organization so in our 24 hours we
managed to get a sort of open source
version of the of the programming
language that had encoded this data we
opened it up and we got the most
bare-bones statistics on who was being
stopped in first in New York City and I
was at the end of the weekend I was like
apologetic I wish I wish we could have
done more and some of those statistics
were were used it when it you know by
the judge who declared stop-and-frisk
unconstitutional so it's so thank you so
it was that was that moment when I was
just like data is amazing but data can
be used against people or could be used
to scrutinize the power the power that
need to meet scrutiny so it's anyway I'm
I'll say more about it later but like
that's that's the kind of like data
scientists life I've been leading which
is like examining how power and data and
are interacting so I actually finished
graduate school in 1993 years these two
started in just a year before and it
turns out that my dissertation was I
think the first big data analysis of
children's language that why do children
say things like braked and goad and how
do they learn to fix their errors and I
wrote shell scripts in UNIX I was quite
the nerd back then I wrote shell scripts
and UNIX to analyze a big data trove
that had just come out which was called
childís or childs
which was conversations of children
talking to their parents and I was I
think the first person to systematically
and automatically analyze this stuff the
first thing I found out was that all the
theories and literature went wrong that
nobody had ever counted the most basic
things of these theories about why kids
would go from saying went getting the
past-tense correct to go getting it
incorrect and then eventually getting
correct and we actually look at the data
they actually only made the mistakes 4%
of the time instead of like 50% of the
time there were all these theories about
why kids weren't so-called free
alternation between the correct form and
the wrong form but when we actually did
the analysis we discovered that people
just notice the mistake so now I
actually have a three and a half year
old and a two year old the three and a
half year old makes mistakes like these
and you notice them you don't notice
when the three and a half year old gets
it right so that was that was an
eye-opening thing about big data for me
with even though we didn't have a term
that was that you could find out that
theories of people may were just
completely wrong and no one had looked
no one had really quantified things
carefully enough before um nonetheless
I'm not really a big data scientist per
se but I sort of someone who watches it
from the outside and I think about it
now
through the lens of artificial
intelligence and I think there are some
things that machines are really
phenomenally good at now and they often
use big data as a solution so one is
spelling machines are really good at
doing spell checking and the old
paradigm for spell checking is you wrote
a program that would say well maybe
people inverted two letters maybe they
used to tease when there should have
been one you have a lot of rules to do
this and someone I believe that Google
figured out that you could just look at
the user self corrections you wouldn't
need to write all of these rules anymore
in order to do the spelling J correction
you could just see they type battery
with one T they didn't get what they
wanted they typed it with two T's they
got what they wanted and then you just
add that to your spell checker and so it
was a completely different way of
solving problems I first learned about
this I don't know in the late 90s or
early 2000s or something like that and
since it's it's swept through through AI
so a lot of things in artificial
intelligence are solved in that way now
using big data on the other hand there
are a lot of things in artificial
intelligence we haven't solved very well
at all that my three and a half year old
does much better than any machine that's
out there and so this is a question I
think about every day is like what can
you get out of big data
and what can't you get out of big data
so my three-year-old has very
comprehensive theories about how the
world works that allows him to like make
up new games interacting with physical
objects to two seconds after he sees
that new object and we don't know how to
program row but robots to do that and a
lot of the things that we do for robots
depend an enormous amount of data the
most impressive thing in AI lately he's
probably alphago which is the world
champion and go effectively right now
but alphago depends on the fact that you
can play the same game over and over you
can play by yourself you can simulate it
perfectly so you can get really massive
amounts of data but human beings can
learn a game like go much more quickly
so how is how does that work so you
didn't mention an intro but one of the
things I'm doing I was actually running
a machine learning company and that's
kind of the question that we're
interested in is what can you do with
small data when do you need big data
when when when are there different kinds
of solutions so that's my take on all
this
so if I have to think about this there
seem to be clearly certain types of
problems where we would call them
low-hanging fruits where we have made
some progress and where they have kind
of touched our lives and then there are
other what you thought was undoable
maybe whatever we think is undoable now
will will be doable in another five to
ten years but but other problems where
we either don't know the answer yet or
maybe we haven't tried hard enough for
some people might argue we haven't
collected enough data yet which I'm kind
of doubtful about so we're where is that
water where's our understanding where we
can make true contribution to maybe
science or maybe personal lives the way
we interact with technology or and when
when does it get harder so what has been
the benefit of biologists looking at all
the DNA how far has it I mean it's great
that we can do that is is that a field
course where you feel like that's where
the true progress has been or is it
actually easier to build a subscription
model for the new york times it turns
out that people in general I found are
more easy to predict than
real life so predicted my people don't
live real life I'll separate that so
like a natural science problems like
trying to predict which genes are going
to go up in which genes are gonna go
down or trying to predict spectrum of
mutations from population genetic sample
the like the predictive power you get
there I have found in general to be
weaker than the predictive power you can
get if you can really observe a lot of
data about the way people behave just my
experience has been that prediction
problems where you're trying to predict
what people do if you have a lot of data
about a lot of people doing it are often
easier than the complicated behaviors of
natural systems certainly in the
biological systems I was working on so
predicting which people are going to
cancel their subscription that's easier
than the biological problems I worked on
even some of the things I did in biology
were really artificial intelligence like
building tools that would help
biologists segment images of movies of
cells rather so cells moving around you
know if you have an image of a cell you
might imagine that you point and click
on every pixel and that's what graduate
students often are doing and it kind of
breaks my heart whenever Isis registers
doing that because that's the kind of
thing you really should automate so one
of the things we did with some cellular
biologists at Columbia was build some
machine learning tools so that they
would label multi-protein complexes
inside a cell as being interesting or
boring basing some criteria they had for
being of interest this is something this
is nothing and they labeled a bunch of
them and we found pretty readily that
you could build a model trained on the
postdoc and then test it on the
professor's label and you could easily
predict what the professor was going to
do for the postdocs behavior like I just
in general I found that predicting
people is actually much easier than
predicting natural systems if you have
enough data and one of the things that
makes biology really hard is that most
of the things that we care about involve
a whole bunch of proteins interacting
with one another so when the human
genome was sequenced the big news was
that humans well in the San Francisco
Chronicle headline was humans survive on
1/3 as many genes as thought so people
basically a guy named
Walter Gilbert made up a number he said
there must be about a hundred thousand
genes he was like a back-of-the-envelope
calculation that he put in a textbook
and everybody kind of spread his number
around and then when they had the first
draft of the human genome they said it's
only 30,000 that turned out to be wrong
it's actually maybe more like 20,000 or
last I heard so even that was an over
estimate and some people were like you
know how can we have all this complexity
in biology if there's only 20,000 genes
and I think the person who got that
right is Jim Watson who helped crack the
structure of DNA he said imagine you
have a play with 30,000 actors and
they're all interacting with each other
well it's a really complicated play at
that point I mean we get lost if there's
like 10 characters in the movie we'll
imagine there's 30,000 returns at 20,000
really each of these proteins can be
spliced in different ways so it's really
like a hundred thousand or something
like that and they're all interacting
with each other in the details of these
interactions make an enormous difference
and so there may not be as many factors
I'm just guessing in terms of the
canceling the subscription also you need
to causally understand things maybe for
some of these biology problems at a
level maybe it's okay if you kind of
approximate which which subscribers are
there but like if you're trying to
figure out a new drug is this drug
really gonna help depression better than
the last drug you need to like have
exact details about the receptor
chemistry it's probably not gonna be
good enough to say yeah these kind of
things generally work together so some
of it's about precision and so I I think
that it's what you're noticing is that
it is sort of an artifact of the things
that we're currently measuring about
people right and so it's probably true
that you know if you're trying to model
you know default rights on credit cards
or subscription cancellations or you
know propensity to retweet something on
Twitter you can you know you can do a
lot better than than what you would for
you know expression of genes but I tell
you those are in some ways the least
interesting questions that we can ask
about people yeah and the reason was
nice to the company but maybe not some
of the reason why we asked those
questions is because that's the data
that we have right now and it's
intuitive to go and critique my own
metal
or you know rather than having a
telescope that was built by you know
astronomers to look at the Stars
you know it's a telescope that was built
by a you know peeping tom to look in the
window of the building next door right
there's the the instruments that we have
as impressive as they are in terms of
the amount of data that they can
generate were built for other purposes
they weren't built to answer the
questions that social scientists care
about they weren't built to answer the
questions that society cares about they
were built to provide a service to
consumers and we generate an enormous
amount of data out of them and it's fun
to try to figure out what questions we
can answer you know it took - what
question is this day - the answer we
call the data jeopardy you get a big
dump of data and then you try to figure
out what question you can answer with
that data you know the scientific way to
do it would be to first start with the
question and then build the instruments
that could help you answer that question
and I think if we sort of you know if we
said rather than trying to predict you
know cancelling a New York Times
subscription we were trying to predict
you know life course outcomes or we were
trying to predict you know the sort of
the most likely source of the next
financial crisis or we were trying to
predict performance of teams in large
organizations or even performance of
organizations we would find that our
predictive power went went way down and
we'd be we sort of be back in the in the
era in the realm of biology again for
exactly the same reason that now we're
talking about complex systems with lots
of interactions and lots of causal
effects happening simultaneously and
it's extremely difficult to sort of pull
out any one factor and identified as the
cause of the thing that you're
interested in so I say we'll get there
you know who care to the point where
things are as bad as they are in biology
it brings up this conversation brings up
a couple points I wanted to make one is
that I think that the sort of standard
of evidence is really different
depending what the question is so like
when I worked in finance and when you
work in relatively high hat high-speed
trading you only you
it's very hard to find a pattern in the
data but at the end of the day you only
need to be right like 51% of the time to
make money if that actually it's
depending on how much you trade whereas
if you're talking about you know
different kinds of algorithms it
actually you should have to prove your
right
and it's as a standard of accuracy what
what means to be accurate and going back
to what you said Gary teasing out the
the causality around human based models
is actually incredibly hard but
sometimes we don't care sometimes we
just want to predict what they're doing
we don't care why someone is gonna stop
their subscription of New York Times we
just predict it and it's relatively easy
to predict it but when we think about
algorithms and other rounds and then
like one of the things I write about in
my book is algorithms that are called
recidivism risk algorithms and these are
algorithms that do a relatively accurate
job at predicting whether someone's
gonna end up in jail after they leave
jail so they go they get sentenced they
they 97% of prisoners eventually leave
some of them come back it's called
recidivism and these are these
algorithms that actually predict
recidivism relatively accurately but
they do not tease out the causality at
all and in fact last week I was really
pleased to see the Pro Publica which is
a really fantastic journalism in in the
in downtown Manhattan group they they
actually studied this specific
recidivism risk score in Florida called
the compass score and they tested they
tested to see how accurate this was now
what they found is that it's relatively
accurate but it has different kinds of
errors depending on the race of the
person who they were they were scoring
and in particular the black the criminal
defendants were much more likely to be
miss scored as high risk of recidivism
and whites were much more likely twice
as likely to be miss scored as low risk
now this matter is because these scores
are actually used to sense
people and in particular people who have
high risk go to jail longer we could
talk about why they decided to do it
that way but my point is like although
it's actually relatively accurate it's
the question is why is it accurate is it
because black neighborhoods are over
policed is it because the questions in
the actual risk score are proxies for
race the answer is yes to all of those
things but all I'm saying is that like
we have we should hold ourselves to
different standards of evidence when
we're using algorithms that actually
predict people depending on how
important it is to their life in a New
York Times op-ed I wrote called eight or
nine problems with big data I co-wrote
with Ernie Davis who's also here at NYU
we talked about something called the
echo chamber effect and the example that
we gave was about using Google Translate
on pages that are in Wikipedia and it
turns out in some less frequent
languages the pages of my QPD are
actually generated by Google Translate
and so there's this echo chamber thing
where the data aren't really real you
are actually giving a nice example or
terrible example of the echo chamber
effect too right so if if the recidivism
rates are actually driven in part by the
policing that is causing the thing then
you get the this you know terrible
feedback loop yeah I can't say enough to
agree with Kathy about how looking at
observational data you just cannot infer
the causality from it the best you can
do is to try to make your data you try
to make your model as interpretable as
possible and then it's essentially a
rhetorical act to try to figure out from
the observational model what might be
causal about it and the case at the
times it's something like you can
predict which people are going to cancel
but that's predicting what's going to
happen in the absence of some
intervention or treatment what you
really want to know is what is the
intervention or treatment that would
minimize that probability and that's
also true in in drug data so you can
look at you know just observational
studies about different people using
drugs and then the outcomes and you it's
been shown David Madigan at Columbia has
done some great work showing that
depending on what you control for in
your model you can make the sine of a
drug be positive or negative that is
just basically looking at people in the
wild as opposed to people in a
randomized control trial there's just no
way to figure out if a particular
medical treatment or medical drug is
actual
increasing or decreasing the risk of
some morbidity or something bad effect
so regardless of how big the data are
it's it's really a tough problem to try
to impose some sort of causal meaning
and this was known long before big data
this is a and in statistics we talk they
talk about structural modeling as
opposed to predictive modeling and it's
a it's a getting from prediction to
prescription is a is a real
philosophical break I'd love to see the
word interpretability get out there more
so in artificial intelligence is the
same kind of issue right now we have
this big complicated model sometimes
with millions of parameters now when I
was in graduate school we were told if a
model has more than like three or four
parameters it's a bad thing but there
are kinds of models that are used in AI
now where there are literally millions
of parameters and there's an issue of
interpretability you don't quite know
what the model is doing and so the model
becomes kind of a black box I mean all
you can say is I've got these 10 10
million coefficients here basically and
I think it makes it risky so you know
that a model works in one condition but
you're not really sure that it works in
another so cuz the driverless car model
you know it works in daylight but does
it work in the rain like you can't just
look at the box and understand how it's
working so you have to try it out
empirically and send some cars out in
the rain and maybe that's a good idea
maybe it's not a good idea
so I completely agree with all of the
caveats being brought up here I just
want to sort of a tendency that I have
noticed in the sort of you know
arguments around Big Data is you know
somebody you know people get really
excited about it and say things like
it's the telescope or the social
sciences and then somebody comes along
and says oh look you know this is
problem you know the data is really
biased or it's it's not measuring the
thing that you actually care about and
so it's kind of the lamppost problem
what you're looking for your keys under
the lamppost instead of where you
actually lost them you know it there's
in dodging ad here that you're not
really understanding because you're
focusing on prediction and so you're
missing the fact that there's this other
kind of process going on that is driving
the outcome and you're and if you
blindly follow whatever inference you
you make using some naive approach you
could not only
do something that's not scientifically
valid it might be socially harmful right
that is all absolutely true and
unfortunately the the response to those
arguments is often Oh data's bad right
we should not use big data we should go
back to trusting our intuitions right
because those are perfect right
those aren't right those are not subject
to all of the biases that that we have
in tight oh those are those are you know
of course valid and scientific and they
feel really good and they're much much
easier to generate than these big data
analyses and I think that is a huge
error right that we can criticize the
scientific the lack of scientific
validity of everything that's been done
with data these days and we should
people like us should be policing that
as as vigorously as we can but the
alternative is not to use data the
alternative is not to sorry not to not
use data right the alternative is not to
sort of walk away from the scientific
method it's actually to be more
scientific right and I think that if you
if you sort of look at the alternative
of you know you just you're a policy
maker and you just you know why people
are criminals right you know why people
are poor you know how to fix the economy
you know how to make America great again
right you know I need evidence anything
sorry Donald Trump is not like your time
or somebody timing that time to first
Trump it right so you know that I think
that we we have to those of us in this
position have sort of a two-sided battle
to maintain where on the one hand we
have to sort of calm the hype down and
make sure that people are being serious
about on the other hand we have to keep
saying but this doesn't mean that we
that we shouldn't be doing this in a
serious and responsible way it doesn't
mean that it's okay to do everything the
way we've been doing it that the the
scientific method is an extremely useful
to land we should be we should be trying
to apply it wherever we can so I 85%
agree with Duncan just says so allow me
to comment on the 15% where we disagree
or where I think you left something out
important which is maybe the word
education or something like that so I
think absolutely the we don't wanna go
back to the dark ages here we don't want
to go back to not using any data at all
or doing things you know just by putting
our finger in the wind and so forth I
totally agree with that but big data has
to be used carefully and I think part of
the point is that people should actually
like as undergrads they should all have
or maybe even before that they should
all have courses in the uses and abuses
of big a or you should all read Kathy's
book I think I'll put that on her back
of the book if it'll be allowed so I
think that it's really important for
people to understand what's - I mean
everybody has to understand the relation
between causation and correlation which
is to say the correlation does not
entail causation and we I worry that
policymakers for example don't
understand these things so the solution
is definitely not the alternative that
you suggested of tossing out the data
that the solution is we need to people
be really educated about it really
educated about what big data can show
and the perils the you know the mistakes
that can happen from biases we'll talk
more about that I suppose the parallels
in inferring correlation and so forth
because we live in an era where big data
is ubiquitous it's going to become even
more ubiquitous you're right we
shouldn't step back but I think that
that give them that this is where we're
going people need to be able to do this
in just the same way that they should be
able to understand small data like when
the commercial says four out of five
doctors recommend you should ask which
five doctors were survey does this
really mean that they were you know a
million people a sample of a million and
I'm getting a report on 800,000 doctors
and they actually recommend this or you
know the advertising community picked
you know cherry picked five and so the
kind of skepticism that we need about
anything that we hear in advertising for
example we need to have in any big data
report so I would like to see a lot more
emphasis on education to expand on that
point there's a literature from around
2004 or so among English professors
trying to understand what we meant by
saying that our students should be
computationally literate
and one of the threads in that
literature is that litora is a really
ambiguous word and let's parse that a
little into functional literacy
rhetorical literacy and critical
literacy and if you go back and read
that literature it's very modern if you
just replace the word computer science
with data everywhere we really are at a
time where we need to educate future
Senators and CEOs or presidents who are
who are multi literate and data so we're
asking some of them to be functionally
literate to learn how to program machine
learning for example some of them to
rhetoric to be rhetorically literate
meaning that they know how to
communicate the results of data and
understand what it means but most of all
we need critical literacy so we need
people who really think through four out
of five doctors or think through the
limitations of the algorithms and and
people who have critical literacy that
sufficient to say that just because
something is an algorithm doesn't make
it unbiased which is a narrative that's
been missing the last few weeks and a
lot of the public dialogue around
algorithms can you actually unpack that
like I know what you meant by that but
so there was this thing with Facebook
right whether whether there was bias in
the algorithm I'll let you unpack that
then know that I can set the stage and
you know the case better but so you know
did did this aspect of Facebook's
newsfeed where they're humans involved
in changing the order of how prominent
something is and and people were aghast
that humans might have played a role
because they all think that Facebook
should just be using unbiased algorithms
so the trouble is there's no such thing
as an unbiased algorithm so I'm not
really gonna comment on the details of
the situation and don't really know
exactly what was done but I think it
suffice us to say that something that's
obvious to those of us working in the
field is that there's no such thing as
something that's unbiased so from an AI
perspective there's there's something
called the no free lunch theorem and
this no free lunch theorem says you
can't have one algorithm that's
universally good at everything that
every algorithm is gonna have its
strengths and it weaknesses I run an
algorithm company now we're trying to
find algorithms that we think fit in the
real world in a particular way but our
algorithms aren't universal they're not
like a universal solvent that could
dissolve everything they're they're good
for some kind of problems and not others
all algorithms are like that and if
you're talking about using an algorithm
with respect to human beings there's
always gonna be some kind of bias so the
first thing you have to do is have
programmers and you know CEOs and so
forth who understand that who understand
that there is no kind of objective truth
out there that whatever algorithm you
pick there is something in there that is
gonna buy us one way or another and
you're trying to like minimize that bias
or minimize you know certain kinds of
errors but there is no absolute truth
and there's no way of taking humans out
and the humans made the algorithm in the
first place and they made decisions
about which data to collect and how to
count them and once you've made those
decisions about what you're counting you
know what things you put together in a
category there's already bias I'm gonna
jump in with an example so I like to say
to to convince people about how simple
this kind of bias creeps into your
algorithm even if you're trying to do
something kind of straightforward
imagine and this happens a lot actually
imagine you run a company and you're
having trouble hiring engineers let's
stay at your company and are successful
and you're like okay well let's just
build an algorithm because there's all
these you know people that send their
resumes and and we want to know whether
they're gonna be successful and I have
these HR people they don't really
understand engineers or whatever so they
try to build an algorithm um and along
the way you have to define success you
if you build an algorithm you have to
say what it looks like to have a hit
right so you can look for the hits and
like your success definition might be
they stay at least for two years and
they get promoted at least once that
might be your definition of success for
okay that sounds reasonable
now imagine that that company has never
had a woman engineer stay for two years
anchored promoted the algorithm that
that used the training data which is the
historical data of your company to be
built when when okay so it's you train
the data you train this algorithm the
algorithm sees an application from a
woman and says oh no she's definitely
not a hit now this is exactly the
problem with causality and correlation
is like the the the algorithm doesn't
think but why wasn't that a hit right
that's something that the algorithm just
picks up from pattern
that it saw in the data so that's what
algorithms do they just they pick up
patterns they don't explain them they
don't understand them and if you blindly
use them then you might be excluding
women instead of looking into the
internal culture of your company to see
what's what's wrong with it so that's
that's a great example I wanted to also
mention putting the science back and I
think this is the I'm going back to the
recidivism risk model which I just I
wanted to back up a little bit give you
a little context the reason judges are
being given algorithm scores high risk
low risk for defendants is because well
in part because we know that the justice
system is highly biased I'm in racist
and it's its historical we know this
there's an enormous amount of economics
literature on that study this sort of
using data and this is an attempt to
improve that and so when I mentioned the
ProPublica report from last week the
proposed report is basically said well
guess what the algorithm were using to
improve our racist practices is itself
racist so okay that's bad but I mean
what I'd like to see is a scientific
data research on on like let's say we
have one jurisdiction where in which the
judges use that model another
jurisdiction which the judges do not use
a model where they thrown out the data
they said let's trust our intuition well
which has better results and what if we
build a new model but then we very
carefully attempt to make more fair are
the results better or did the judges not
use those scores if they don't agree
with them you know it that would be
science that would be how to take us you
know take the instead of get it giving
up data like doubling down and saying no
we want data to work for us for us as
the public and I I think this this
notion of critical thinking that's come
up with respect to to data science they
I think that's exactly the right idea
and I would just expand that to say we
should be teaching people to think
critically about all kinds of claims
right it shouldn't matter
whether this is a claim about data or a
statistical model or whether it's a
claim that's based on a really
convincing narrative right or a claim
that is based on my personal experience
or my level of success or you know or
some moving story that I can tell you
about some person some individual person
you know it's it's a when doctors give
advice to to patients on on the efficacy
of medicine or some treatment they they
can give you the sort of statistical
evidence that you know this has a you
know 75 percent efficacy rate but then
if they add at the end of that and the
last person who received this had a good
outcome or a bad outcome they can
dramatically alter the patient's
willingness to take the to take the the
treatment right so you can a treatment
that is sort of 75 percent effective if
the last patient had a bad outcome
they'll say no if it's 30% effective but
the last patient had a good outcome
they'll say yes so like enormous
differences in in in sort of actual
ethics as he can be can be moved around
with with stories and anecdotes and and
I think what we should be pushing for is
is a you know educated mind that can
look at any kind of claim and say oh
that doesn't actually make sense so
what's the evidence for that
or does that generalize or you know you
know what about the alternative
explanations you know is that
correlation or just causation I mean all
of these problems predate data they're
all problems with human reasoning and I
think that if all that this discussion
does and all of this excitement about
data does is highlight all of these
problems then you know then and generate
a citizenry that is more aware of these
sorts of deceptions then that will be a
useful service in the flip side of that
is that you probably can't really do a
good job of being critical about big
data unless you have a general education
in critical thinking hmm excited I
completely agree with if you like it's a
special case of being critical to look
at these data questions if you don't
already understand how to reason
critically than knowing what a t-test is
isn't by itself going to help you I'm
90% agree with you but we are sort of at
a new point where we actually need
models of our models like for most of us
you know species history as as theorists
you know we make a model and we pretty
much understand the model this is a case
where because the models are themselves
learned by algorithms that are pretty
damn complicated we don't really even
understand our models which gets back to
the interpret ability of things like
deep neural networks which years ago I
was talking to a deep learning expert
and I said what about interpretability
they said I'm anti interpret ability
interpret ability is a distraction so I
had a friend that Google just say who
gives a bleep about interpretability the
models work and that that kind of said
right where we can make models that work
really well but we don't we don't know
why they work and from an engineering
perspective sometimes you do not care
but when that model is implementing
policy that affects people's lives you
better care oh so I want an only 50%
agree this is the previous thing which
is about education I'm not saying you
shouldn't be able to think critically
everybody needs to think critically but
I don't I don't think that I mean I
think we have a problem that people are
too intimidated to stake a claim against
a model they're like oh I don't know
math I don't know computer science I
don't have the right to question this
model but when we're talking about and I
think we're going to talk about
education we're talking about a teacher
being assessed whether they're a good
teacher or not based on a score that
they will not be explained that nobody
understands that they do not understand
that doesn't give them advice about how
to get better and that they might lose
their job over they can they can call
[ __ ] right then and there they don't
need to know math so that um you know
I'm not really disagreeing that we
should educate who'd would ever disagree
but I don't think that we need to sort
of have masters level education about
their stuff in order
- sometimes just commonsensical II say
this makes no sense and it's not right
but let me only agree ten percent with
you because the thing is master here
five masters education makes it sound
like it's a step beyond I'm just saying
there's multiple ways to promote
literacy I don't have to teach you a
functional literacy before I teach you
critical literacy we should like we like
people who like do this for a living we
should be able to figure out a
curriculum in which we teach students
well enough to call [ __ ] on
algorithms before we've taught them to
do some fancy math and the so I wrote a
book about the problems with common
sense right so this is the that
everything is obvious once you know the
answer right that the claim here is that
common sense and in interpretability can
actually be the problem right that that
we you know our brains our causal
inference machines you know we see
things happen and we tell a story that
says X happened and why happened Y
happened because X happened you know
pretty much all of history is this right
pretty much everything you read in the
newspaper is this right it is and it is
all entirely in violation of any sort of
you know relatively modest standards of
scientific communities right it's all
just storytelling and my favorite is
when the new says stocks rose today on
you know fear of some every explanation
here about market for examples right and
and almost every explanation you hear
about anything right has this problem
that I just saw a sequence of things
happen and then I strung together a
plausible story that makes it sound like
it was a causal mechanism and so
interpret interpret ability he's so
powerful in our minds it weighs so
heavily on on on our on our emotions
that when we get something that sounds
plausible we're done right we just pop
out a copy to your study hmm there's a
great study by Ellen Langer on the point
of people just need in it something that
looks like an explanation so back in the
days when people went to the library and
they copied lots of things she did this
study where you go up to somebody if you
just cut in line people are very
annoying but if you said excuse me I
need
I need to cut in line because I need to
make they don't even hear the rest of it
you just say because I need to make some
copies they'll let you go ahead as if
you had said you know because I need to
get this in or I'm gonna lose my job or
something like that I mean there's some
manuals that there's so many you know
examples of this that psychologists have
shown that you know if you if you have
two explanations and one is
statistically more powerful and the
other one is a more interesting story
then people will believe the one that's
the more interesting story I mean
there's there's so many ways to show
this but I think the point that I would
push back on is that introducing data
and evidence to this world of just
unbridled intuition is mostly a good
thing right that it is there are all
kinds of problems with it but the other
problems are a hundred times bigger
right so I think that yes we should be
not rushing to embrace you know
everything that is claimed based on
statistics and and and I agree with you
that sometimes it can seem intimidating
but there's a lots of ways to intimidate
people without we are intimidated
without giving a number here about the
extent to which I agree it is I want to
push back on interpretability a little
bit so it is true that humans see
explanation where explanation does not
belong so they you know see a series of
lottery numbers and make up a story and
then they think they know what's gonna
happen next and clearly there's nothing
really going on but I think if you're
using a model in a real world context
it's good if you know why the model does
what it does and if you just treat it as
a black box I think there are a lot of
risks that inherent in that so you don't
know even particularly their problems
with machine learning right now where
people don't actually know how to
engineer what these things they work in
a context and you can get guarantees
that they will work if the data are the
same but you don't really know what the
data are the same means and you don't
really know what will happen at that
regime so in the classical engineering
regime you build things within
tolerances and then you build new things
out of the smaller parts you build an
airplane and you know it's gonna work
because each screw is within a
particular tolerance and so forth with
machine learning you build things they
kind of seem to work and you don't know
what regime might change such that they
no longer work
and that's partly a problem I'm
proposing that was taking this
particular debate maybe four take it out
so after panel conversation of course
what happened here was what I expected
to happen that I don't have to do any
more writing yourself all by yourself
but I do want to give the opportunity to
our audience to kind of poke a little
bit deeper and some of the things that
were brought up and we have light so I
think there are some people with
microphones around so they are hands up
can we please have whoever might start
somewhere
thank you do we have mics and can you
wait yeah that way yeah please just
because it's probably being recorded it
might be nice to get mics to the
questioners this one my grade we can
find another mic yes Danny okay so I had
an observation when you were all talking
about the algorithm model versus
intuition and that sounded a little bit
narrow to me like what else could there
be besides intuition it seemed like
something was being left out as far as
human beings are concerned whether it's
human reasoning or something
but is it just algorithm versus
intuition and intuition is not good I
think it's a shorthand I mean algorithms
themselves embody intuitions and they're
their intuitions of the programmers
there but I think that the point that
Duncan was rightly making is there are
things where people solve things without
really looking at the data at all they
just say it feels to me like such and
such and they're not very quantitative
about it and they ignore the data that's
out there or don't try to collect them I
mean even when the data are there
there's some intuition that goes into
how you evaluate that data so I mean I
think I think it was a simplification
for you know conversational purposes but
there is something real to it too which
is like the way that cities used to run
and be like people think well maybe we
should just send more garbage trucks
over here in the way that New York City
runs now that bloom
kind of changed the regime is you
collect data you figure out you know
where where the garbage trucks actually
get used and so for many places where
New York City used to just have a couple
of guys and it was usually guys sitting
around making their best guesses about
things now we collect a lot of data we
can do better I think analysis and many
of those cases not all also just to jump
in like in many contexts there's also
rules right so I mean for judges they
have sentencing guidelines there's laws
maybe 20 years from now Facebook's
algorithm will be actually regulated we
don't know or maybe they'll will just
own everything and it'll fit at all
media so whatever they say goes so wow
there's a lot of questions now okay yes
thank you for an amazing discussion for
me the problem is not with taking a
certain data set and try to like dissect
it and ask questions the problem is that
we're trying to cry wolf for example
before we have examined we have
exhausted all the questions or all the
data sets that we should examine so when
we talk about like racism in the United
States and we only look at like a tin
data frisk there could be many other
data sets that actually would dispel
that there is racism let's say against
whites in in other data sets but we
silenced these so when do we exhaust
when do we say that like how many data
sets or how many different questions we
should ask before we can we can make
that interpretation over specific let's
not stop moreover there's certainly
other data sets that show racism besides
das stop-and-frisk you know just this
week there was this story about the
courts where they randomly assign the
accused to different judges and they
showed us some amazing correlation
between the ethnicity the judge and the
ethnicity of the accused so for the
victim we think we might that's really
couldn't victims so let's not stop
wishing that we didn't stop looking
this is like an old question in the
philosophy of science right that you
know that is a you know what's the
relationship between the questionnaire
and the data right that that to some
extent the data that you have is is is
constructed by the question that you
think to go on answer right that you're
interested in something so that there's
no guides how you design your data
collection strategy and so in some sense
you are you know biasing the answer that
you get by the the fact that you go and
look at something you don't look at
something else you know I don't think
that anyone has resolved this question
as a philosophical matter that I think
is a practical matter this is a good
Chris's response is the right one that
we just have to keep doing more and keep
you know engaging in a critical dialogue
about it I think this is a point very
well taken that if I may express an
opinion on this I think something has
changed between the old days where you
collected a data set to answer a
specific question and you gave it a lot
of thought ex-ante how are you going to
sample it and and what you're going to
collect in order to answer a question
whereas in the day and age of big data
we kind of live with these exhausts of
data that are collected by somebody else
and it turns out to be incredibly tricky
to actually track down what really
happened during the data collection
process if I wasn't present somebody
hands it to me so I think there is an
interesting again it's an unknown
unknowns it's very hard to assess a bias
if I have no X and their understanding
of that and I think that is a topic that
dissolves more understanding that not
withholding we have encountered that
problem before maybe in different areas
and different disguises but I think it's
a valid point of investigation as we
check our own kind of limitedness he was
probably taking another question but
I'll just say one very quick word on
this which is scientists know that I
mean good scientists know that we never
fully answered any question and then we
have finite resources so we're
constantly at every moment saying what's
the best resource that I can use now
what's what's the thing that's going to
give me the most leverage next but we're
never saying to ourselves we fully to
answer the question where's the mine
ever has
oh the Micah's makes the rules yeah um I
should moderate and we can get the next
Mike to the next person so next time we
ask somebody has a Mike Thanks
so you talked about how algorithms have
like like have outputs like all the hits
and you made a extra you made the
example of like the women in the company
right if if an algorithm of terms
returns a hit doesn't it have a reason
to return a hit can't we have the
algorithm express why it returned that
hit well that's the whole question of
interpretability so I mean every
algorithm can give an answer in some way
but if you have an algorithm that has 10
million parameters that's the algorithm
has put in a whole bunch of numbers that
say this is more important than this is
less important and so forth
eventually gets to the point where the
human can't really understand it you can
still even in those systems dump those
10 million numbers you can kind of say
well why did you do a rather than B it's
because I multiplied these 10 million
things by these constants and these 10
million things by those constants and
you know this sum was greater than that
one so you can still you can back
engineer it a little bit from from like
the parameters in your neural network
but the problem is at that level it's
not really communicating anything to
human beings other than that these are
my numbers I just jump in that there are
new algorithms that like our models of
models as Chris was mentioning where
they they don't try to understand the
source code and this they just try to
sort of and you might have mentioned
this like reverse engineer like what did
you say no to this because this person
was a woman now that's hard to do is in
general because usually there's no
actual place on your resume where you
say woman so I was being a little bit
sloppy when I said that it's probably
not a direct gender bias right they but
there's lots of things on your resume
that might be correlated to being a
woman so it's actually kind of tricky to
do this even if that's your intention is
to back out explanations for why this
was a hit why this was not a hit but but
we are making progress on that kind of
thing
and just to amplify that if the if the
problem is that the way that data was
generated right if the you know the if
the absence of successful women in a
company is a product of some other
process or a nation in some sense the
algorithm can't give that reason right
it can't know that because it wasn't
given that information to begin with and
the same is true of the of the the
recidivism algorithm right that that you
can look at the outcome and say oh you
know and this is where intuition is
actually extremely useful you could say
oh I wonder if that's because of this
other thing that isn't in the data but
the algorithm itself would have I can't
imagine designing an algorithm unless it
had some more general model of the world
built into it to be able to say oh maybe
maybe the data itself is not very good
maybe you should give me a different
data set we say two quick things there's
at least two reasons why you can't say
why for statistical modeling now one is
the thing that we were saying earlier
about deep learning big neural nets or
in general like models that were
themselves learned by a computational
algorithm are so big that we need a
model of the model the other thing is a
simple statistical observation and this
was true long before we had big data so
the one example is called Simpsons
paradox there's a canonical example of
this in the admissions rates at Berkeley
in the 60s where somebody pointed out
that admission rates seem to be
systematically lower for women than men
so is the admissions process at Berkeley
biased against women well if you dig a
little deeper you realize that there's
an unobserved confounder in the
departments and it turned out that women
were had a preferential application rate
at the departments that were really
difficult to get into and so that there
actually was like a lawsuit resolved by
Statistics and it was long before big
data so any statistical observation if
you want to ask why what you're really
asking is what would have happened if I
could have changed that one variable
right and that gets us back to
counterfactuals and causality versus
correlation and the problem is that
correlation is not causation although
causation does cause correlation which
is why they're correlated one very brief
exam
that I think makes it clear here's a
very simple mathematical model it is it
says that your IQ is correlated with
your or your ability to answer questions
on a particular IQ test
he's correlated with your foot size
turns out to be true and so you conclude
from that if you have bigger feet then
you're gonna be smarter or something
like that it's a very simple
mathematical model there's not a lot of
variables involved and it turns out to
be true for a strange reason which is
you include children in your sample and
the smaller children can't answer the
questions because they don't have a big
enough vocabulary right and so if you
just look at the equation you say
there's a simple equation I can
interpret Li I can interpret what's
going on here but really you need to be
able to reflect on it before and the
causal principles before you can you can
use it and there's no substitute for an
experiment all right next question
going to the question of uncovering
biases and in algorithms and like the
why question the reflective question
what do you think about the idea of
using crowdsourcing or something like
that as an approach where the algorithms
are put out there for tests in terms of
coming from a practical standpoint as
well how difficult or easy to see that
where people can actually to uncover
these biases I think a related question
is about that that kind of brings to the
fore is about the openness of the
algorithm so one of the reasons why I
think people are upset about some of the
things that Facebook does is we can't
crowdsource to evaluate the algorithm
because we don't know what the algorithm
is so there are a lot of places in
modern society where you know one
particular group has access to some
algorithm that has a lot of influence on
the world and other people feel bit
rightly that since they don't know what
that algorithm is they don't they don't
know whether another one would be better
or fair or things like that I have a
blog called math babe and a couple days
ago I posted on my blog this lawyer
turned data scientists work on guess
what racism and sentencing
I do think about other things by the way
he had posted his source code on github
so it's completely transparent everybody
could have accessed it he invited other
people to access it later that morning
he posted a correction to one of the
things he had claimed because someone
made someone checked and they they made
this point and he fixed it then the next
day someone posted on as a comment on my
blog I
Moose's interesting so I did some tests
myself here's my source code and I'm
like this is cool this is the way we do
it and it was from the Georgia
sorry Virginia justice system the
Virginia justice system put out their
data for Pete for scrutiny and you know
that's rare it's one of the other things
we wanted to be practical about it I
would love to audit the entire justice
system for racism but it's very
political I mean very very few
jurisdictions actually want to put that
data out there and partly because of
privacy could prob l'm x' but but also
because that who wants to be like the
next Ferguson report like front page New
York Times oh we found yet another like
racist system you know a lot of
political risk and I'll just mention
briefly one of the reasons that Facebook
doesn't put its algorithms out is
because people might gain them the same
thing with Google so if Google actually
published its search rank algorithm then
everybody goes out and they they put
little invisible things on their web
pages to make their web page than those
prominent so sometimes they're actually
I think legitimate reasons why big
companies don't want to release the
algorithms but it's still you know not a
great thing from the public
understanding but if you if you really
want to understand a system there's no
substitute for open source like because
the systems we're talking about here are
algorithms they are code and so
distributing those code is qualitatively
different than just trying to eat
crowdsource just based on reading a
paper or something like that there's an
old saying and software engineering that
many eyes make all bugs shallow meaning
if you get a lot of eyeballs to review
the same source code whatever the
problems are in the bug and whatever the
problems are in the code eventually
they'll be very minor problems so two
thumbs up for crowdsourcing hi I just
had a question on I understand you've
mentioned that all the pitfalls but
given the situation that especially in
the medical sciences area where there is
a lot of electronic medical record data
it's generated it's not generated for
the purposes of research at all or not
generated for the purposes of
understanding causality its generated
for finance for billing for claims for
etc but the fact that it's out there and
it's observable
is there a way to state that the current
the the data world currently with the
big data issues especially in the
medical area can focus on just
observation you know because not
everything needs to get to wise so for
example yeah when you see like
ProPublica was being mentioned they had
a couple of stories on malpractice in
the Medicare data sets they you know you
really don't need in those situations to
truly answer why those many yes you do
when you do an investigation after that
but the data's role is to basically just
tell you that there's an anomaly or
there's a thing that is noticeable and
observable and that in itself is is not
sufficient but it's it's the first step
to getting to wherever you need to be
next and I think I just tremendous
amount of power there I mean it's sort
of you know heterogeneous effects that
that you know that it's it's possible
that you know a particular medication
has you know a very high efficacy rate
on a very small number of people are in
a very special type of person it's
possible that there are you know you
have all these interaction effects that
people test for but there's you know
massive sort of uncontrolled natural
experiment happening in the world where
people are being assigned different
drugs at the same time and and there's
evidence for interaction effects out
there in the wild and and and yes you're
right that even if even if you can't
necessarily infer causal mechanisms from
this data the first step on the way to
identifying those causal effects is to
is to notice that there are associations
there to begin with
yeah and I guess that causation causes
correlation which is why you use the
correlation to suggest where you should
do experiments you just need to diagnose
for diagnosing I don't necessarily need
causality at all I mean as long as I can
figure out that this is the problem and
then we have medical literature to tell
us how to treat it but in terms of
societies and inequality yes you have
great medical facilities here in New
York City but if you live in
God forsaken place in the middle of
nowhere the doctor there may not ever
have seen a case like yours but if there
was a machine that says ha that looks an
awful lot like X maybe you want to go
and test that there's really no need for
causality initially as low just because
the symptoms correlated with the cause
and it's enough get to the next level i
partly disagree with that but I'm not
gonna go into that bit but make a
different point which is I think in
medicine the big problem is that we
don't use the data that we could have
well enough so one of the big problems
is that hospitals don't share data and
so there are many problems for which you
could do with even these kind of
superficial analyses better if the
hospitals would share or you think about
say rare diseases and you know there may
only be 12 patients and if you can put
those 12 patients together put their
data together you might be able to
figure something out but if 12 different
hospitals have the data and don't want
to share it then it's a real problem so
I think there's a major problem in this
country of not and off data sharing in
medicine there are other cases like some
of the best work that's been done in
genetics has been in countries where
they have very accurate records about
who's related to who and over what's the
span of time and so you can get large
sample sizes so you can say are these
two things genuinely correlated at all
forget about getting to cause out of it
let's just see if they really correlated
or if it's just an accident of my sample
you know I only have a hundred people so
medicine is a place where big data could
have a much bigger impact if people
would actually get that data there one
last example would be radiology it's
pretty clear that we can eventually
replace radiologists with deep learning
systems and then in countries where they
can't afford radiologists or there isn't
one there are things like that you know
be able to use cellphones to do
radiology but we can't get to that point
until there's more data sharing and more
autumn autumn eyes recording you know
imaging the the image their digital
digitalization of the images that are
out there I think in another huge area
of application is on genetic resistance
to viruses for example right
you know if just one person in the last
Ebola epidemic was was genetically
resistant to Ebola and we could
understand what it was about the you
know their genetic makeup
that that made them resistant that might
shed light on novel mechanisms and novel
treatments that would help you know
potentially millions of people you know
you could imagine like that being you
know we've got the the sort of global
health care system is you know if we
could centralize and analyze that data
would there may be you know thousands of
very sort of one-off interesting special
cases that could be tremendously
informative for medical science I think
they the analogy that I that I find
striking is some you know YouTube videos
you know you see these YouTube videos
where that you know the cat is doing
this just totally amazing thing or this
kid can like you know name every capital
of every city of every country in the
world and it may just be sort of one
instance of that in the world right and
and before YouTube to people would have
seen it right they would have just said
oh that was kind of cute what my
three-year-old just did and no one else
would ever know about it and now you
know YouTube kind of puts it up there
and suddenly millions of people could
see this totally incredible thing that
has only ever happened once ever in all
of history and you imagine what the
analog is for medical science if this
totally incredible thing that has only
ever happened once in all of history
could be known about by everybody then
that might be a lot more useful wouldn't
and even better if you can find five
people with the same thing because the
real way you crack these genetic things
is you find five people that all have
the same mutation the same place I mean
you're on to some get a couple of
siblings hi so I mean I guess Duncan
become a panel with me reference to the
importance of the scientific method but
don't we have to first decide exactly
what it is we mean by the scientific
method then perhaps be realistic about
how widely applicable that is because in
the physical sciences you know there's a
lot of them say some observe
observational Sciences like astrophysics
and cosmology we can repeat the same
experiment over and over and over again
you know and you know every year I'm
sure hundreds of thousands of high
school students in the u.s. take a penny
or take a pendulum and measure how its
frequency depends on length and they all
you know are from a few screw-ups they
all get the same result right so so
that's
that's completely repeatable and the
same would say you know something much
more advanced like the LHC if you see a
sump pump in the data you just keep
running the accelerator went over over
again you accumulate more and more data
and get your 5 Sigma van right whereas
in the social sciences let's call them
or hidden biology that's not necessarily
something that's possible it is a more
of an observational paradigm so
shouldn't be get a more realistic about
how applicable the scientific method is
in those cases or does it is that
anything I think the things it's a it's
a totally reasonable question and I
think you know if sort of you know you
know here is where we are right now and
here is you know applying the scientific
method to everything and you know the
the even if it's true that only sort of
you know this much of interesting things
in social science can be can be usefully
addressed with something like the
scientific method because everything
else is this unique one-off thing that
will never happen again that where we
have an enormous way to go before we
have exhausted the potential right so I
think that would be the first thing that
I would say is that it's not about that
the claim is not Oh everything can be
reduced the scientific method the claim
is that we're not we're not trying to do
it for anything right now and so there's
an enormous potential for improvement
and then the second thing I would say is
that even when you run up against the
limits of you know say you know you
can't go to war with half of Iraq and
not with the other half and see how it
works out better you know you can't sort
of do a/b tests on foreign policy you
can't you know rebrand half the company
and not rebrand the other half of the
company and see which one works out but
so there's a lot of things where you
just have to sort of think hard about
what to do and and and and do your best
but I think even in those or where it's
unethical or impossible to do an
experiment because you can't you know
randomly assign people children to
different parents to see you know what
kind of family structure you know
causally affects their outcomes right so
there's all sorts of reasons why you may
not be able to to do
experiments there's all sorts of reasons
why you might not be able to gather the
data that you need to get but even then
it's still useful to think about the
scientific method if only to understand
the limits of what you can know right
and I think that a certain amount of
epistemic modesty is useful that sort of
understanding what you don't or can't
know can can help you avoid disastrously
bad decisions that come from from hubris
and overconfidence so I think there's
two very different but complimentary
ways in which the scientific method is
absolutely applicable to the social
world so unfortunately I think we have
time for one more question and a mic hi
my name is samsara Taylor I write for
revolution newspaper and I wanted to I
wanted to first I wanted to say to you
Cathy if you did nothing else besides
expose the racism and the justice system
it would be highly commendable we're
living in a society where black people
and brown people are being killed by
police every day and are being carted
off to prison and locked away and it's
very important I just want to commend
you for that and I want to push back on
the idea that was posed before about I
think it's true if you look for bias
against white people if that's the
question you ask you can find it I want
to push back on the idea that you answer
that by asking more questions because I
think there are some questions that are
actually not just morally invalid but
scientifically invalid like for instance
to give an example that's not in the
social realm you could look for every
example where Darwin made a prediction
about how evolution functions how it
plays out where he was wrong and amass
huge amounts of evidence right
creationists do it all the time it
doesn't actually disprove his core
theory there are questions that are
actually scientifically ungrounded to
ask and I'm you know I know it's a
bigger discussion some of what I'm
raising but I guess methodologically
there's something I would like it if
people on the panel speak to both in the
in in any realm but including in the
human social world how do you answer
that
what's a valid question to ask because
you have to go from more than just
Duncan you made the point if you go if
you start with a dump of data and figure
out what you can answer with it that's
different than starting with a question
and figuring out then how would you go
look for that and how do you inform a
valid question that's my first question
and my second question is shorter which
is we are living in a time when there is
so much big data on all of us available
to the big government and I'm just
curious if you guys have anything to say
about the dangers and I know it's in the
title the perils I wondered if any of
you had anything to say about that okay
um so I disagree with you I don't think
that's an invalid question I am a
completely certain that the data will
show the racism against black and brown
people in this country to a point beyond
which you know only people who are
absolutely refusing to see it I mean of
course everyone can cherry-pick right
let them go ahead and do that but if the
data we're out there and we could audit
it and we could look at State City we
could of course at some granular level
because it's gonna be a lot of data
you're gonna find whatever you're
looking for that that's that's not
scientifically valid and because we will
have so much evidence no one will listen
to that that's what's great about
science right that's that's ideally what
we would want we would want those crazy
people just to be crazy go ahead you
know everybody has the right to just be
blind the other thing I wanted to say
it's kind of the same thing you know we
didn't talk at all about privacy and
that was intentional actually we were
just like we're not going to talk about
privacy because then we'll never stop
talking about priority two seconds but
my my one thing about privacy in the
last 38 seconds is that you know when
when people are worried about their
privacy is being violated the the sort
of dystopian future that they're afraid
of is already happening but it's
happening to like poor minority people
in this country so I went to Camden New
Jersey
the police department there with a
contingent from the White House and I
learned about all the different
surveillance stuff going on there and
and I'm like people we don't have to war
we don't have to like imagine what's
going to happen in the future it's
already happening
and the futures already here is that's
not evenly distributed yet particular
it's being used by the most powerful
against the least power exactly that's
what happens when you introduce a new
potency into the species is the people
who already have a lot of potency are
gonna exploit that to be more potent
well is that we is that us as data
scientists it's were over time so I'm
gonna say one sentence in my book I
actually call out data scientists we
have too much power we are de facto
policymakers for exactly the reasons
that we just talked about and we need to
have we need to have this the the
questions about bias about
discrimination but how we use data
science how we use big data has to be a
conversation at the level of the public
we should consider ourselves
interpretive interpreters we decide we
decide with the public we have like okay
what was the decision that's what we're
gonna do and we should have to stop
being policy makers you know a lot of
time yeah what happened in finance so I
mean after the financial services there
were plenty of essays from quantitative
people saying oh don't blame us it was
our managers I mean it's it is it is a
potency and potencies will be used by
different people in different ways so
you definitely should think through
about the implications of any new
capability that you've been given so I
want to in the interest time I realized
that we have come to our end and I will
not take it personally if anybody
including anybody in my panel has to run
out I think there is a very strong
tension and give-and-take and this is a
conversation we didn't
I'd say we're not going to talk about
privacy we said we're not going to start
talking about privacy before we're done
with anything else because then we will
not get to talk about anything else and
we kind of left it also partly to you to
pick that topic up if you felt that this
was something first and foremost I do
feel that we have a large responsibility
and I think we all here very much agree
on on that at the same time I'm probably
your most likely villain as I am your
first line of defense because I'm the
one who is working in a company and when
my CEO comes to me and asked me to do
something I have the choice to make well
how far I'm willing to go with that and
where do I push the boundary and I think
this is partly why we're here why we are
looking for this course and that's where
kind of our all opinion come together it
is easy to just basically push the data
scientists their fault I think no in the
sense of are we part of the problem we
are as least as much part of the
solution as we might be part of the
problem and I I wish that we could share
the complexity because it often seems
like they're easy answers when this
comes to transparency why can't we the
number of very good reason why we can't
why can't we just go back to intuition
or a very good answer for that one too
so it will remain one of the struggles
and a push on poll that we face as a
society and it has to involve all of us
in finding the right mechanisms tools to
get there so thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]